The term “spoiler alert” is all it takes
to send the Internet into a frenzy.
Moviegoers love reading up on their most anticipated
films, but the world wide web can be a minefield
full of secrets viewers don’t want to know.
Whether it’s a plot twist, a surprise character
appearance, or even the ending of the movie,
audiences have to be careful about what they
read and watch, or the whole experience could
be ruined.
Sometimes, even when they’re extremely careful,
they still find out about spoilers from some
unlikely sources.
Here are 10 movie secrets that were spoiled
before release.
Captain America: Civil War
Marvel fans were ecstatic when it was announced
Spider-Man would finally be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, making his debut in Captain
America: Civil War.
For most of the marketing campaign, the studio
kept his role in the film under wraps, and
there was a debate as to whether the web head
would be part of Team Iron Man or Team Cap.
Marvel spilled the beans when the second Civil
War trailer premiered and ended with a shot
of Spidey stealing Cap’s shield and announcing
himself to the world.
It made sense from an advertising perspective,
but some would have preferred Spider-Man didn’t
show up until the actual film.
Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
Just about everything from Zack Snyder’s
superhero crossover proved to be divisive,
and that includes the trailers.
Warner Bros. released a preview in December
2015 that received a healthy dose of criticism
for playing as a condensed version of the
feature film.
It outright revealed that Doomsday would be
the big bad that Batman, Superman, and Wonder
Woman team up to fight, taking the attention
away from the titular Batman vs. Superman
conflict.
By the time the film arrived, audiences were
just waiting for that sequence instead of
getting lost in the story, which certainly
didn’t help its mixed reception.
Star Wars: The Phantom Menace
Having a talented actor like Liam Neeson appear
in a Star Wars movie is a treat for fans,
but he unfortunately wouldn’t be around
for long.
Viewers learned that his Qui-Gon Jinn wouldn’t
make it out alive when the movie’s soundtrack
track list was released, including the tune
“Qui-Gon’s Noble End.”
That stripped the film of some much-needed
dramatic tension and was just overall disappointing.
For their part, Lucasfilm seems to have learned
from the mistake, withholding both the score
and novelization for The Force Awakens until
the day Episode 7 had already premiered.
They deserve credit for that, if nothing else.
Cast Away
As one of the best actors of his generation,
Tom Hanks can sell audiences on just about
any concept, and Cast Away was the ultimate
test.
Hanks spent most of his screen time isolated
from society, with only a volleyball named
Wilson to talk to.
What should have been a suspenseful tale of
survival became just another film when Cast
Away’s trailer actually revealed that Hanks
made it off the desert island alive – having
been gone for a period of four years.
The movie is still good, but imagine how much
more compelling it could have been if the
studio left that one big question untouched.
Speed
One of the most tense thrillers of the 1990s,
the drama of Speed comes from a bus constantly
driving at 55 mph or more – or it will explode.
The people who cut the film’s trailer must
have missed that memo, because they spoiled
a key plot development in the preview.
It was bad enough they included a shot of
the bus exploding, but it was quickly followed
by the cast reacting to what had just happened.
Knowing that everyone got off the vehicle
alive before it blew up basically ruins the
enjoyment of watching Speed – even though
there was still a train at the end.
Creed
One of the many recent soft reboots passing
the torch to a new generation of characters,
Rocky installment Creed placed the spotlight
on Adonis Johnson – son of Apollo Creed.
The trailers promised a return to the stripped
down gritty drama of the original film, and
something a little extra.
The second preview revealed that the Italian
Stallion himself would fall ill at one point
in the movie.
This was a gut punch, but it wasn’t necessary
to sell Creed to general audiences.
Seeing Stallone as Rocky again was enough.
If the studio had kept his bout with cancer
completely under wraps, then maybe that plot
point would have hit harder than it did.
Wreck-it Ralph
These days, not even coloring books are safe
from movie spoilers.
Audiences don’t learn that King Candy is
the main villain of Disney’s Wreck-it Ralph
until the end of the film – and that he’s
a completely different character from what
he says he is.
But children eager to color their favorite
video game characters ahead of time learned
the surprise well in advance.
That’s right.
A Wreck-it Ralph coloring book was released
two weeks before the movie, and it spoiled
the film’s climax.
This may not be the most highly publicized
entry on our list, but there’s no denying
it’s an odd and frustrating way of having
the experience ruined.
Star Wars: The Empire Strikes Back
Arguably the most famous plot twist of all-time
is Darth Vader’s startling revelation to
Luke Skywalker.
Even people who haven’t seen the Star Wars
films know about it.
Before George Lucas unleashed that secret
on the world, he kept it so hidden, a fake
line was used during principal photography.
But David Prowse – the man in the Vader
suit – knew about it well before 1980.
During a fan event in 1978, Prowse was quoted
in a newspaper as saying Vader is Luke’s
father.
Studios these days have media trained their
actors to perfection, so one can only imagine
what would have happened if Prowse pulled
this off today.
X-Men: Apocalypse
No matter the era in which it takes place,
an X-Men film is always going to find time
for Wolverine.
The poster boy of the franchise, it’s impossible
to separate Hugh Jackman’s mutant from the
series.
But for a while, it looked like this summer’s
X-Men: Apocalypse was going to break the streak.
That is, until a trailer was released weeks
before the film premiered and ended with Wolverine
bearing his bloodied claws for the camera.
Throw that in with the revelation Quicksilver
is Magneto’s son, the Apocalypse marketing
team left everything out on the table to get
fans interested.
Those are our picks for movie secrets that
were spoiled before release.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones were you able to avoid?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!